muchos de los conceptos que hemos
aprendido en cálculo multivariable
tienen sus bases en el álgebra lineal ya
que utilizamos mucho estas herramientas
para poder resolverlos llevando esta
misma idea para aplicarla a ejercicios
que ahora no van a ser lineales por
ejemplo si esta vez nos tomamos una
función déjame escribirlo me voy a tomar
una función que la voy a aplicar a un
cierto vector al vector x bien y voy a
suponer que ahora lo que va a hacer esta
función es mandarme este vector xy a
otro vector que de igual manera va a ser
un vector bidimensional pero ahora me
voy a tomar la siguiente transformación
voy a pensar que esta primera entrada de
este vector me la mandé a una función de
estas dos a la función x más el seno
de james déjame ponerlo así el seno de
james mientras que en la segunda
componente me voy a tomar a gem y le voy
a sumar y para hacer esto un poco
simétrico ya sabes mis debilidades por
la simetría voy a sumarle el seno de x
y vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa cuando
le aplicó esta función a este vector
bueno no forzosamente necesitan este
tipo de simetría entonces en el vídeo
anterior de un pequeño repaso de cómo
pensar acerca de las transformaciones
lineales y de algunas ideas del álgebra
lineal sobre cómo codificar una
transformación lineal usando una matriz
y también trabajamos en esta cuadrícula
para visualizarlo aquí quiero mostrarles
cómo se ve esta función como una
transformación en el espacio es decir le
voy a decir a la computadora que tome
cada uno de los puntos de esta
cuadrícula y si este es el punto
james quiero que lo mueva sobre el punto
x + seno de james coma
james más seno de x
y aquí está como se ve bien la
cuadrícula se vuelve muy ondulada
bastante rizada y como ves esto de plano
no es una transformación lineal las
rectas no permanecieron rectas y observa
que ya no son paralelas ni uniformemente
separadas en algún sentido hay mucha más
información la que intervienen en
funciones no lineales que la que
interviene en funciones lineales y ya
que esto se ve bastante complicado creo
que podría ser más fácil que lo
entendiéramos si nos fijamos en un solo
punto así que permítanme buscar un punto
digamos no se me voy a fijar qué es lo
que pasa con el vector pri medios
y medios pero estos valores van a ser
fáciles de evaluar y entonces vamos a
ver qué obtenemos si metemos este vector
bueno si metemos este vector observa que
aquí me va a quedar lo siguiente me va a
quedar en la primera componente x x spri
medios entonces me quedaría pin medios
más el seno de cero pero el seno de cero
es cero así que no hay que sumarle nada
más y si me fijo en la segunda
componente me quedaría bien pero lleva
la cero entonces no hay que sumar nada
más el seno de pi medios pero el seno de
pi medios es lo mismo que uno entonces
aquí simplemente me va a quedar uno así
que vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con
este vector con este punto el punto
primero a cero y vamos a ver si en
efecto llegamos al punto y medios como
uno espera déjame especificar que aquí
le aplicamos la función eso es
importante y bueno si regresamos aquí y
nos fijamos entonces en el punto medio
es como 0
y medios es aproximadamente 1.5 así que
va a estar por aquí y esperemos que este
punto se mueva al punto 21 entonces
solamente debería de moverse en una
unidad verticalmente y si sólo nos
enfocamos en ese punto durante la
transformación observamos que
exactamente eso es lo que pasa solo se
mueve una unidad verticalmente y por
supuesto a todos los puntos les va a
pasar algo similar porque bueno esta
función parece ser bastante complicada
ahora la computadora está tomando cada
punto y moviéndolo hacia donde debería
ir así que después de haber dado el
repaso sobre el razonamiento de las
transformaciones lineales y cómo
codificar las en matrices como vimos la
vez pasada ahora vamos a ver algo que
podría parecer completamente
inabordables ya que sin duda tienen que
guardar mucha más información que sólo
cuatro números para registrar a dónde va
esto pero esta función tiene una
propiedad agradable una propiedad con la
que lidiamos todo el tiempo en cálculo
multivariable es lo que llamamos lineal
local déjame escribirlo
realidad local y lo que significa es que
si tuviera que tomar de nuevo nuestra
configuración inicial y hacer un
acercamiento en un punto dado así que
voy a acercarme a este punto de la
izquierda y está cuadrado en la parte
superior derecha solo muestra la versión
ampliada de ese punto en primer lugar
voy a agregar algunas rectas más a la
cuadrícula son rectas realmente muy
cercanas que hacen una cuadrícula más
pequeña pero esto nos va a ayudar de
hecho podemos verlo en la imagen
ampliada muy bien y puedes ver que todas
estas rectas están paralelas y
uniformemente separadas
ahora cuando reproduzco la animación voy
a tener este cuadrado amarillo que está
haciendo que el acercamiento siga el
punto en su centro
entonces si hago la transformación y
nosotros solamente estamos viendo que
pasa el cuadrado ha empleado este
cuadrado va a seguir ese punto durante
la transformación y ahora podemos ver
dentro de esta versión ampliada que
bueno en primer lugar sigue siendo no
lineal las rectas se curvan un poco
estás de acuerdo ahora parece un poco
más una función lineal
temas como las rectas de la cuadrícula
que comenzaron horizontales y verticales
y estaban paralelas y uniformemente
separadas y de hecho digamos que lo
acercó aún más a un cuadradito más
pequeño voy a hacer aún más pequeño el
lado izquierdo y de nuevo voy a agregar
rectas a la cuadrícula rectas alrededor
del punto que vamos a seguir así está
densamente comprimido y bueno esto es
solamente para ayudarnos a visualizar
mejor las cosas podría poner rectas o
puntos o cualquier cosa que nos ayude a
visualizar qué es lo que va a pasar así
que esta vez reproduzco la
transformación y ese cuadro ampliado
monitorea el punto que estamos viendo y
también el entorno alrededor todos los
puntos alrededor realmente se ven ahora
como una función lineal y entre más me
acerque más precisamente se verá como
una función lineal así que esto provoca
la duda de que si estamos viendo
alrededor de algún punto específico el
cual voy a llamar el punto
es cero james 0 ok y me fijo en este
punto de aquí entonces puedo encontrar
una matriz de 2 x 2 me voy a aplicar en
una matriz de 2 x 2 ok que correspondan
a la transformación lineal que se ve
alrededor de él que representa la
transformación lineal de esta función al
menos de lo que se ve en esta función
más complicada que lo que se ve esta
transformación que parece lineal
alrededor de este punto y es justo a lo
que nos referimos con local en el
siguiente vídeo voy a mostrarles cómo se
ve esta matriz en términos de las
derivadas parciales para nuestra función
original entonces nos vemos hasta el
siguiente vídeo